Whether or not you enjoy Big Brother, Survivor,
or Keeping Up With the Kardashians, there's
no denying that these long-running reality
shows have figured out a winning formula.
But a lot of shows weren't so lucky.
Things can go wrong on set all the time, and
when dealing with regular amateurs instead
of professional actors or experienced showbiz
vets, that risk is even greater.
From hardcore drug use to gruesome felonies,
these reality series all got canceled due
to some major mistakes.
Pretty stupid
It isn't easy keeping up with the Kardashians,
which Alexis Neiers and her family found out
the hard way while making their E! reality
series Pretty Wild, which ran for only one
season in 2010.
The show followed Alexis, her sisters, and
their mom, former Playmate Andrea Arlington.
Alexis was arrested for participating in the
infamous Hollywood "Bling Ring," and jailed
for robbing Orlando Bloom's house, all in
the first episode!
While the legal trouble so early on should
have been something of a red flag, the clincher
came later when photos were leaked of Alexis
and her sister Tess smoking.
The show was canceled for good, and both girls
attended rehab.
"December 1st, 2010 was the last time I used."
Armed and foolish
You'd think the only idiot mistake in a show
called Armed and Famous would be the premise:
training celebrities to be police officers,
and actually making them do the job while
being filmed for a TV show.
"No John is going to hurt these two girls.
Not on my watch!"
The stupid doesn't stop there, though.
The 2007 reality TV dud was canceled after
just four episodes when a woman filed a lawsuit
against CBS Broadcasting for $1 million.
Apparently the famous cops had ransacked her
apartment looking for two suspects before
realizing they were at the wrong address.
The network also cited the show's low ratings
as part of the reason for the cancellation.
Editing error
There's nothing quite like stripping contestants
of all their clothing to raise the stakes
on a reality series.
This was the simple concept behind VH1's Dating.
Contestants disrobed down to their birthday
suits and went on "dates" such as sipping
cocktails by the pool or engaging in some
light mud wrestling.
Romantic, right?
Although the participants needed to bare it
all during filming, they were apparently promised
that their naughty bits would be blurred out
when the show aired.
Unfortunately, whoever was in charge of the
blurring made a major error during the July
31st, 2014 broadcast.
Then-28-year-old model Jessie Nizewitz was
wrestling with her date on the beach when
viewers caught a brief unblurred glimpse of
her private parts.
Nizewitz quickly became the target of ridicule
across social media, and filed an ultimately
unsuccessful $10 million lawsuit against VH1
owner Viacom, along with two of the show's
production companies.
Eventually the Parents' Television Council,
who were staunchly against the show, managed
to wrestle 90 percent of Dating corporate
advertisers away from the series.
The show was canceled shortly after its third
season in 2017, with poor ratings cited as
one of several reasons for the decision.
Good grief
If you thought the world of funeral homes
was an untapped treasure trove of reality
gold, well, there might be a reason for that.
In 2014, Lifetime was set to produce Good
Grief, a reality series that centered around
the Johnson Family Mortuary in Fort Worth,
Texas.
But the series wound up six feet under before
it ever got off the ground.
On July 15th, 2014, the landlord paid his
tenants a visit and discovered eight rotting
bodies hidden beneath the funeral home.
When reporters and paparazzi showed up, owner
Dondre Johnson initially told the spectators,
"That's great advertising, because in a few
days from now we'll be on a reality show so
I want all this media."
Ultimately, Johnson was found guilty of theft
for stealing money from customers and neglecting
the bodies of their loved ones, and sentenced
to two years in prison and a fine of $10,000.
Unsurprisingly, the network pulled the plug.